tell me if this sounds familiar
a man walks into a store he searches for
a certain section books he takes out a
can of lighter fluid I know why he
burned the books why because he wrote
Sydney Hall one of the best friend of
our time I've been searching for him for
years wonder if you've know Fishman
sittings one of our brightest students
because permit
what if I wrote enough what would it be
about it's your name melody no no no me
I need keep burning away from me because
it's fun
[Music]
you've been number one on the bestseller
list for eight months I'm seeing face
things that aren't there right something
that's gonna shake people up you should
get on be sure to take me with you she
write about me you know my father is
this is me I should write a book about
him you'll be singing a different tune
tomorrow what happens tomorrow this book
has a dangerous sign of the times I
apologize for nothing
[Music]
I don't know what he wants he knows
everything about me
no one is claimed to see or hear from
Sydney Hong over five years now how is
that possible
everywhere I go he's with me you were
the last people to see him alive
that's not a beginning to a great book I
don't know what is
the entire course of a person's life can
change a millisecond
this has to end Sydney
this is beside something you think
give me the information of our Sydney
Hall
and we'll never sing again
[Music]